♪ ♪
>> Chris: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
HOSPITALIZED AT WALTER REED
MEDICAL CENTER AFTER TESTING
POSITIVE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
AS NEW CASES EMERGE AMONG HIS
TOP ADVISORS AND ALLIES.
RUNNING IS ONCE AGAIN FROM
BALTIMORE, DR. TOM INGLESBY,
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
HEALTH SECURITY AT JOHNS HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY.
DOCTOR, I ALWAYS HAVE THE TAPE
TO ASK ABOUT A SPECIFIC CASE TO
A DOCTOR WHO HASN’T SEEN THE
PATIENT, BUT FROM YOUR
EXPERTISE, KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THE TREATMENT THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS RECEIVING, THE FACT
BEEN HOSPITALIZED,
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
HIS CASE, HIS CONDITION?
>> Dr. Inglesby: WELL, CHRIS,
I THINK THE NEWS THAT WE HEARD
YESTERDAY WAS LARGELY
ENCOURAGING, THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT REQUIRING
OXYGEN, THAT A NUMBER OF LAB
CHECKED ON MY TESTS WERE
REPORTED TO BE NORMAL AND HE WAS
ABLE TO DELIVERED
YESTERDAY.
WHAT WE HEARD FROM THE FROM THE
CHIEF OF STAFF WAS CONCERNING,
THE FACT THAT AT LEAST
MR. MEADOWS SAID HIS VITAL SIGNS
WERE CONCERNING ON FRIDAY, THAT
HE WAS REQUIRING OXYGEN.
THOSE ARE WORRISOME THINGS.
IF AT LEAST THEY SUGGEST FOR THE
PRESIDENT DOES HAVE PULMONARY
INVOLVEMENT FROM COVID IF THOSE
THINGS ARE CORRECT, AND THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF TESTS THAT I
PRESUME WERE DONE AT WALTER
REED, INCLUDING A CHEST X-RAY,
CT SCAN, WHITE BLOOD CELL COUNT,
INFLAMMATORY MARKERS, IT WOULD
BE USEFUL TO BE ABLE TO JUDGE
HIS RISK GOING FORWARD TO KNOW
WHAT THE RESULTS OF THOSE TESTS
WORK, BUT SO FAR THE NEWS THAT
WE’VE HEARD HAS BEEN
ENCOURAGING.
>> Chris: THAT’S ENCOURAGING
TO HEAR.
BUT YOU ANTICIPATED WHERE I WANT
TO TAKE THIS.
THE PRESIDENT IS A 74-YEAR-OLD
MAN WHO IS TECHNICALLY OBESE.
HOW LONG BEFORE WE HAVE A SENSE
WHETHER HE’S OUT OF THE WOODS,
AND IN WHAT ONE POINT
MARK MEADOWS WAS SAYING THE NEXT
48 HOURS, THE DOCTORS WERE
SAYING 7-10 DAYS.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO KNOW
WHETHER HE’S OKAY AND I GUESS
PART OF THE QUESTION IS, WHAT IS
THE LIKELIHOOD, BEING WHERE HE
IS RIGHT NOW THAT HE CAN
PARTICIPATE IN A PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE IN 11 DAYS?
>> Dr. Inglesby: IT IS ALWAYS
VERY DIFFICULT TO MAKE JUDGMENTS
ABOUT INDIVIDUALS, ESPECIALLY --
UNLESS YOU’RE REALLY INVOLVED IN
THE CARE.
OVERALL IN THIS AGE CATEGORY,
PEOPLE THE PRESIDENT’S AGE, IT
WAS A STUDY DONE BY CDC IN
JANUARY TO MAY TIME FRAME THAT
SET A THIRD OF PEOPLE HIS AGE
WERE DIAGNOSED WITH COVID WOULD
BE HOSPITALIZED AND THAT THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT MORTALITY RATE
IN THAT AGE GROUP.
THE PRESIDENT IS RECEIVING
EXTRAORDINARY CARE AND IT LOOKS
LIKE IS DOING WELL BUT IT’S
CERTAINLY A SERIOUS DISEASE FOR
PEOPLE OF HIS AGE AND WITH
UNDERLYING CONDITION.
WE DO KNOW THAT SOME PEOPLE HAVE
SYMPTOMS THAT ARE MILD AND
RECOVER AND DO EXTRAORDINARILY
WELL IN THE FIRST WEEK BUT THERE
ARE OTHERS THAT IN THE 5-10 DAY
TIME RANGE CAN HAVE A RELATIVELY
QUICK DETERIORATION AND DEVELOP
MORE SEVERE SYMPTOMS.
IT’S VERY DIFFICULT TO JUDGE
THAT AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN, THOSE ADDITIONAL TEST
RESULTS WOULD HELP US MAKE SOME
JUDGMENT ABOUT THE LIKELIHOOD OF
HIS DISEASE GETTING BETTER OR
THE POTENTIAL FOR WORSENING.
IN TERMS OF THE DEBATE, I THINK
IT’S TOO SOON TO SAY.
GO AHEAD, CHRIS.
>> Chris: IS GOING TO ASK YOU
THOUGH, BECAUSE THIS DOES GET TO
THE BIGGER ISSUE OF THE PROPER
SAFETY REGULATIONS.
THE RALLIES THAT THE PRESIDENT
HELD WHERE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHERE THERE, OFTEN TIMES WITH NO
SEPARATION, THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THEM NOT WEARING MASKS AND THEN
AS I DISCUSSED WITH STEVE
CORTES, THE PRESIDENT’S FAMILY
AND ADVISORS IGNORING THE
REQUIREMENT AT THE DEBATE THAT
THEY WEAR MASKS.
AS A PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL,
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> Dr. Inglesby: YEAH, I THINK
THERE IS CLEAR DANGER IN HAVING
EVENTS WHERE THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE CLOSE TOGETHER WITHOUT
WEARING MASKS FOR A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME, ESPECIALLY WHERE LOUD
VOICES ARE USED.
WE KNOW VIRUS IS SPREAD BY LOUD
VOICE MORE EFFECTIVELY SO I
REALLY THINK LARGE GATHERINGS
LIKE RALLIES SHOULDN’T BE
HAPPENING AT THIS POINT FOR ANY
PURPOSE DURING A PANDEMIC, WHICH
IS, IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS,
ACTUALLY BEEN GETTING WORSE.
AND I THINK WHEN THE COMMISSION
SETS RULES FOR PREVENTING
TRANSMISSION DURING DEBATES,
THEY SHOULD BE FOLLOWED.
PEOPLE SHOULDN’T BE MAKING THEIR
OWN DECISIONS, THEY SHOULD BE
FOLLOWING THE RULES THAT ARE
ESTABLISHED BY THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS WHO SET UP THOSE
DEBATES.
>> Chris: I WANT TO PICK UP ON
A QUESTION I ASKED MR. STEVE
CORTES.
AND THAT’S THE CONTINUITY OF
GOVERNMENT, BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT IS IN THE HOSPITAL.
AS WE SAY, HIS PROGNOSIS IS
UNCERTAIN IN THE COURSE OF THIS.
YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, THE NEXT
IN LINE TO THE PRESIDENCY, GOING
AHEAD WITH PUBLIC RALLIES, GOING
AHEAD WITH THIS DEBATE.
IS THAT A SENSIBLE ACTION FOR
HIM TO TAKE, OR DOES IT RAISE
CONCERNS ON YOUR PART ABOUT THE
NEXT PERSON IN LINE TO THE
PRESIDENCY?
>> Dr. Inglesby: MY VIEW AT
THIS POINT IS THAT THE REST OF
THE DEBATES, THE
VICE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE AND IF
THERE ARE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATES
SHOULD BE VIRTUAL.
I THINK AT THIS POINT WE’VE SEEN
FROM THE FIRST DEBATE THAT THERE
WERE UNANTICIPATED VERY LARGE
RISKS THAT DEVELOPED AROUND THE
DEBATE AND DAYS AFTERWARDS AND
IN FACT, BY PUBLIC ACCOUNTS, IT
LOOKS LIKE THE VICE PRESIDENT
HAD A MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT
ON TUESDAY, PERIOD OF TIME WHERE
HE WOULD BE PRESUMED TO BE
CONTAGIOUS AND IN MY MIND IT
SEEMS LIKE THE VICE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE IN QUARANTINE, EVEN IF
HE IS GETTING TESTED ON A DAILY
BASIS AND SO IN ANY EVENT I
DON’T THINK IT IS A PROPER RISK
TO TAKE TO HAVE HIM GATHERING
WITH SENATOR HARRIS IN PERSON
AND IT COULD EASILY DO THIS
DEBATE VIRTUALLY AS WAS DONE IN
THE PAST FOUR AT LEAST IN THE
CASE OF KENNEDY AND NIXON, I
KNOW WE DID VIRTUAL DEBATES BUT
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH PURPOSES I
THINK IT WOULD BE SAFER TO HAVE
THESE LARGE GATHERINGS AT THIS
POINT GIVEN THE RISKS OF THE
PANDEMIC.
>> Chris: I WANT TO PICK UP ON
SOMETHING YOU JUST SAID, WHICH
IS THAT IN FACT THE PANDEMIC IS
GETTING WORSE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SENDING A
CONSISTENTLY OPTIMISTIC MESSAGE
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE WITH COVID-19
IN RECENT DAYS.
HERE’S SOME CLIPS FROM THAT,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE ROUNDING THE TURN, WE
ARE ROUNDING THE CORNER OF THE
PANDEMIC.
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IS BEING
MADE AND I SAY IT AND I’LL SAY
IT ALL THE TIME, WE ARE ROUNDING
THE CORNER.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE END
OF THE PANDEMIC IS INSIGHT.
>> Chris: DOCTOR, WHERE ARE WE
REALLY WITH COVID-19 AT THIS
POINT IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> Dr. Inglesby: WE ARE STILL
IN THE MIDDLE OF A DANGEROUS
PANDEMIC IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PAPERS THIS
MORNING AND THE DATA, YOU CAN
SEE THAT SOMETHING ON THE ORDER
OF TWO-THIRDS OF THE STATES IN
THE COUNTRY HAVE HAD INCREASES
IN COVID NUMBERS IN THE LAST
WEEK AND WE ARE SEEING, AS YOU
SAID EARLIER, IN THE 40,000
RANGE OF CASES EVERY DAY.
HOSPITALIZATION RATE HAS JUST
BEGUN TO TAKE UP AGAIN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, AND THERE ARE PLACES IN
THE COUNTRY IN THE MIDWEST,
PARTICULARLY IN WISCONSIN, WHICH
ARE HAVING EXTRAORDINARY
NUMBERS, BY HIGHEST NUMBERS YET.
PLACES IN WISCONSIN HAVING
TROUBLE ACCOMMODATING ALL OF THE
SICK PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING SICK
WITH COVID, SO I THINK PEOPLE
NEED TO REALLY CONTINUE TO TAKE
THIS VERY SERIOUSLY TO AVOID
LARGE GATHERINGS, WHERE MASKS,
PHYSICALLY DISTANCE AS THEY HAVE
BEEN OVERTIME AND HOPEFULLY IN
THE MONTHS AHEAD WE WILL BEGIN
TO GET VACCINES COMING ONLINE,
BUT IN THE MEANTIME IT’S
IMPORTANT TO TAKE ALL THE
PRECAUTIONS WE’VE BEEN TAKING
ALL ALONG TO PREVENT
TRANSMISSION.
>> Chris: I’VE GOT ABOUT A
MINUTE LEFT AND YOU’VE ANSWERED
PART OF IT, BUT WHAT IS THE
BIGGEST LESSON THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD TAKE ON THE FACT THAT
EVEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WHO WAS IN THE
MOST SECURE HEALTH BUBBLE OF
ANYBODY MAYBE IN THE WORLD CAN
STILL GET THIS, WHAT’S THE
LESSON PEOPLE SHOULD TAKE FROM
THAT AND SPECIFICALLY WHAT THEY
SHOULD AND SHOULDN’T DO?
>> Dr. Inglesby: I THINK THE
LESSON IS THAT THIS IS STILL THE
SAME VIRUS.
THE VIRUS HASN’T CHANGED.
WE HEARD EARLIER THIS WEEK THAT
MOST OF US ARE STILL SO MIKE
STILL SUSCEPTIBLE TO THIS VIRUS
IN THIS COUNTRY, ONLY A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF US HAVE BEEN
INFECTED AND RECOVERED AT THIS
POINT, SO PEOPLE SHOULD TAKE IT
VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE DO HAVE TO FIND A BALANCE IN
TERMS OF LIVING OUR LIVES AND
TRYING TO GET THE ECONOMY
MOVING, BUT EVERYTHING THAT
PEOPLE CAN DO AS INDIVIDUALS IN
TERMS OF MASKING, PHYSICALLY
DISTANCING, AVOIDING LARGE
GATHERINGS, WE SHOULD BE DOING
THAT.
AND HOPEFULLY IN THE TIME AHEAD
WITH MORE DIAGNOSTIC TESTING AND
WITH THE COMING OF NEW THERAPIES
AND VACCINES, THE RISK WILL
CONTINUE TO GO DOWN, BUT FOR
NOW, NEED TO TAKE THIS VIRUS